faites une bonne séquence mais je suis
pas un intervieweur jeu pas pour poser a
mis d'accord vous aidera à vous faire un
réquisitoire bas madame on débat
continue voilà vous nous dites que ce
que parce que marina bay n'ont ils pas
crédible voilà c'est ça que je dis je
pense que ces changements de pied sur
tous les sujets y compris les plus
importants d'année en année montre
qu'elle n'est pas crédible je pense
qu'elle met 15 ans à se rendre compte
qu'une idée qu'elle a proposé un jour
était en fait mauvais donc le temps de
maturation d'une idée de marine le pen
ça me fait dire qu'il faut pas se
précipiter quand elle propose et donc je
pense que eric zemmour vous rend en
effet un service immense en vous
dédiabolisant parce que en effet il est
sans doute bien pire que vous sur les
questions sur les nazis qui a dans son
équipe et s'est même si vous vous disiez
beaucoup de bien d'alain soral n'y a pas
si longtemps et en plus il vous rend
mais oui madame les céréales il ya pas
si longtemps mais c'est une réalité vous
avez dit beaucoup de bien à la salle
dont on savait déjà très bien qui
c'était un peu importe peu importe même
sur la peine de mort vous avez changé
dit matt dit des trois fois que vous
n'êtes pas vraiment capable de dire mais
peut-être dire ce soir que vous êtes
contre la peine se sont fait avoir de
temps de parole tellement vous avez
parlé monsieur que vous avez un long
temps de parole je sais très bien donc
pardon vous n'êtes pas si différente que
ça de lui mais vous rends service
puisque il vous dédiabolise et d'une
certaine manière ils vous crédibilise un
peu dans l'espèce d'atonie général et
moi ce que je pensais que vous n'êtes
pas crédible que vous perdrez à nouveau
cette élection présidentielle et que
donc vous rendez service à emmanuel
macron qui est en train de voler
l'élection présidentielle aux français
avec votre complice messieurs consigne
et moi je comprends que vous soyez un
peu amer je veux dire parce que votre
candidate qui était donné au début
d'ailleurs de cette campagne très haut
en capacité on disait mon ex est la
seule qui pouvait battre aujourd'hui non
seulement elle n'est plus du tout en
capacité ce cas les quatrièmes ou
cinquièmes de la compétition il reste un
mois et de soi bien sûr il reste trois
semaines tout peut arriver mais quand
même par expérience je peux vous dire
que il est quand même assez rare si vous
voulez qu'on voit des courbes se
croisent et radicalement dans les
derniers moments mais bon ça peut
imaginer que ça peut arriver mais je
comprends que vous soyez un peu agacé
mais surtout second tour on voit que
elle n'a pas la capacité de gagner face
à emmanuel macron est elle la moins que
moi donc je comprends cette amertume
mais on aurait pu évoquer
le sujet j'avais dit quelque chose vous
nous avez privé s'est vite et débattre
de tout vous avez fait un réquisitoire
très désagréable faut le dire mais c'est
ma vie j'ai dit la vérité marine le pen
pas mal non mais vous avez j'avais fait
du mal c'est quand vous avez dit laisse
à leurs marines de facebook ont signé ça
me fait pas de mal pour vous vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que les compteurs
étaient remis à zéro au second tour donc
si là donc les sondages du second tour
moi je les regarde pas trop journal les
sondages de premier tour et moi moi ce
que après c'est vrai que après faut voir
voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est le
candidat nous avez raison donc voilà
donc et valérie pécresse pour avoir ses
chances voilà au second tour c'est le
passé et au second tour on remet les
compteurs à zéro à peu près c'est vrai
qu'après il ya le débat du dodo d'entre
deux tours c'est pas ce qu'il peut se
passer mais voilà il ya qu un problème
si vous voulez c'est que
valérie pécresse à la peau ou prou
exactement le même programme qu'emmanuel
mâcon résulte donc le problème c'est
qu'entre quelqu'un qui est en poste et
qui défend le programme de valérie
pécresse c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas
évidemment ils vont le guen face à
valérie pécresse emmanuel macron va être
considérablement avantage est il présent
sera notre g vous le savez c'est
exactement la même chose c'est le style
qui n'a rien fait de la retraite à 65
ans mais vous serez retraite à 65 ans
d'ailleurs où 64 ans j'aimerais bien
qu'on en parle de minutes parce que la
retraite à 64 ans ça va avoir une
conséquence faut que chacun comprenne
sauve elle c'est la baisse en fait
dépenser à la belle oui bien sûr ça va
sauver le système des retraites dites il
ya d'autres moyens d'ailleurs il n'est
pas en danger leur système des retraites
contrairement à ce qu'on nous dit mais
ça va surtout permettre pour ceux qui
vont la mettre en oeuvre de faire
baisser de 10% en fait l'intégralité des
pensions pourquoi parce que déjà au
moment où nous nous parlons au moment de
la retraite à 62 ans la moitié des gens
qui arrivent à la retraite n'ont pas de
retraite pleine c'est à dire qu'en
réalité ils ont une retraite des côtés
imaginez vous que si c'est déjà le cas à
62 ans à 64 ans alors quasiment
l'intégralité des français n'auront pas
de retraite pleine l'objectif c'est de
faire baisser en fait de manière
générale l'intégralité des pensions de
10%